Although mutations that can cause color blindness have
been found in over 56 genes on 19 different
chromosomes. The most commonly inherited form of the disorder
comes from mutations on the X chromosome. So here's
the zoomed in pair of the sex chromosomes where
the X chromosome is a part, in an individual
that's XY. Remember the Y chromosome is much shorter
than the X. Now the X chromosome is about
155 million base pairs from tip to tip. And the OPN1LW gene is located right
here close to the end of the X
chromosome. Notice that there's no corollary because the
Y chromosome is much smaller and doesn't
have the same genetic information that the Y
does here. The OPN1LW gene, is a gene with 6 exons on the X chromosome spanning
about 15,000 base pairs of DNA. And it has an allele that's associated with red,
green color blindness. After a transcription and
splicing of the gene, we're left with the
coding region as 1,095 nucleotides long. And
so after translation we end up with a
protein that's 364 amino acids long. Remember, this
map is pretty easy. We just divide 1,095
by 3 to get 365 and then subtract 1 to get 364 because
remember the stop codon doesn't code for an amino acid, it's just empty.
It means stop. Now one allele of the OPN1LW gene
contains a C, a cytosine to T, to thymine mutation at position
739 of the coding region. I've highlighted the change in red here.
Now, what I want you to do is, use
the genetic code that you learned about in lesson
3 and you can find in the instructors notes
on this page. And determine the change expected in
the amino acid sequence and select the type of
mutation that this C to T change is most
likely categorized as. Now if you have trouble answering
this you might want to review mutations from lesson 6.